[Music]
hey everyone how's it going it's my eco
today I wanted to do a video that
several of you have asked for actually
which is the what's in my backpack video
and before we get started I wanted to
say thank you to Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video
whether you need a website domain or
online store make it with Squarespace
okay so let's jump in so I wear a
backpack to work every day and I thought
I would introduce the backpack first and
then maybe go through the contents of it
I have it all laid out there and so I'll
talk about each one by one so hope
that's cool so without further ado this
is my backpack so it's a backpack from
High Sierra I don't remember what the
model is actually called but I'll leave
it in the description down below um it's
funny how I came to find this backpack I
actually have gone through two other
backpacks before I found this one
actually saw someone wearing this at the
airport one day and it just looked
really cool and I was like I want to buy
it and then I went online to the High
Sierra website and I bought it and it's
been working pretty well for me I think
I've had it for about a year now so
here's the front of the backpack I've
decorated it with a couple of pins that
I own these two I got from WBC last year
this one says hello and this one is the
old Mac logo which I totally love I had
other ones on here I think but they've
all fallen off they've all just like
retired from my backpack to say I don't
want to be there anymore but these ones
have stuck on which I am really grateful
for because these are my favorite the
other ones on here is a youtube pin that
I got from I think Google I want to stay
at Grace Hopper they were giving out a
bunch of pins and so I have this YouTube
pin as well as this patch on this side
the YouTube package is actually peeling
off I should probably sew it on so the
other ones I have on here are this is a
Wong foo forward pin I'm one of your
care holders on patreon and I love them
I've been watching them since I was in
high school basically and so they sent
pins to all of their care holders which
I thought was really nice so this one is
from my friend Andy he's a fellow Iowa's
developer and he made an initiative
called wu-tang clan
which is obviously a play on the word
for the group routine clan which is
pretty funny he's selling these pins and
using the funds to help lower the
barrier for people from underrepresented
backgrounds break into the tech industry
and I'm such a huge fan so I wear this
one probably on my backpack other than
that I'm just some main features there's
a side pocket here there's a side pocket
here there's a pocket here and a zipper
here so I really like the modular Ness
of this and this one as well there's a
pocket right here if I open this up
right here there's this kind of big
section actually that opens up like this
so this is actually all just like one
pocket there's no specific like dividers
or anything inside but I can actually
stuff a lot of things in here when it's
great because I can just stuff like
jackets and like big things and just
like basically make this as bigger as
small as I want it to be which I really
like about this backpack and then of
course over here is the zipper for my
laptop and so this is a very specific
like laptop compartment there's like one
divider in there but I like that my
laptop actually stays separate from the
rest of the compartment because then
it's just easier to get to I don't have
to wade through a bunch of other things
to get there and the back looks like
this so it's pretty standard I wouldn't
say it's like North Face level but it
does a job and I like just how simple it
is and how easy it is to get to
everything so let's dive into what I
have inside which is actually not inside
here as you can see it's like all air so
first off is my laptop obviously this is
like the thing that I have a backpack
for I have the 15-inch MacBook Pro I got
this from work got a bunch of cool
stickers and stuff on it which maybe
I'll talk about somewhere else maybe on
Instagram or something don't forget to
follow me there next up is my bullet
journal I got this one from Bear and fig
and I don't want to show you what's
inside per se but it's got the dotted
grid I don't know if you can see that
but yeah I've been bullet journaling
since end of last year actually and I
liked it a lot I was actually inspired
by my friend Charlie Murray and also
Matt Raglan who both have their own
YouTube channels to create a bullet
journal because they made a video about
their own ones and I was really inspired
so yeah I really like this one it's the
barren fig confidant in flagship size so
I have this one thing kind of to go
along with that I also is carry a pen
with me this is the Muji
pen I guess in 0.38 which is the
smallest size these pens are so good
they write so well and I love them and I
always just buy huge box of them so this
is kind of like my bullet journal II
stuff if you want to see a video about
how I bullet journal then leave a
comment down below maybe I'll make it if
y'all are interested next up so I wanted
to talk about books so I carry around a
couple of books at least one book with
me I have a pretty long commute I think
from door to door it takes me about an
hour and a half to get to work and I
spent a long time on the train and so I
bring some things with me so that I
don't get bored so right now I have
these two my backpack this book is Miss
Burma it's a novel about a family going
through all the term oh that Burma went
through for the last 100 years and it
just follows all their lives
I'm almost half way through it and I
really like it I realized I don't know
anything about the history of Burma so I
saw this book and I really liked the
cover
uh-huh but I'm reading it and it's
really interesting I like books that
tell the story of people a lot and so I
really like memoirs and this is kind of
like a memoir it's fiction but I'm
really enjoying this one right now so I
usually like having maybe like one
fiction and one non-fiction book I like
nonfiction because it's me like learning
things and absorbing new material but
sometimes I just want to be like
transported to a different world and so
I like having a fiction book on hand for
that but this is my nonfiction read
right now which is the managers path a
guide took tech leaders navigating
growth and change by Camille Fournier
she used to be the CEO of CEO CTO of
Rent the Runway this book was
recommended to me by all of my
co-workers it's great for anyone who's
either a software engineer or a manager
or if you're looking to become a
director VP or CTO or CEO but yeah I'm
like halfway through ish I'm just
kind of jumping around because it's one
of those books but yeah this is my
nonfiction that's been in my backpack oh
also I usually keep a highlighter with
me for these non-fiction reads so that I
can just like go through and highlight
stuff so yeah I don't know I got this
one for free it's blue
it's nice next so like I said Mikami's
really long and that's really what a lot
of the stuff in my backpack is for so if
I'm not in the mood to read I'll listen
to music or podcasts and so I actually
bought these pretty recently these are
the Bose QuietComfort twos there are
bushes headphones with noise
cancellation these ones are really
popular I've seen them everywhere on the
train at airports and stuff I actually
bought this from a vending machine at an
airport but I really liked it
the noise cancellation is okay it
doesn't get rid of all of the noise but
it does get rid of like low humming
noise that honestly you don't realize
that you hear but you do so yeah I
really like these ones they're like this
and they're adjustable so I always keep
these in my backpack unfortunately I do
have to charge them every once in a
while but usually just do that when I'm
at work so see so yeah they come in like
a nice little nifty case should I just
keep it like this in my backpack
oh speaking of charging things I also
usually keep a portable charger in my
backpack this one I don't know where I
got it and this holds our charge so well
usually keep this one in an iPhone cable
with me so I don't know if they all have
been to the Bay Area before but usually
the weather doesn't change all that much
it ranges from like BB low 40s to like
80 something so it never gets super cold
but we do have a little bit of a rainy
season from like January to April so I
always keep a portable umbrella with me
I wish it was a little bit lighter but
otherwise it might not be a sturdy not
that this one is super sturdy anyways I
actually just got this out of market
some time cuz like it was raining and I
didn't bring my umbrella and it was like
pouring so I just ran in and got this
and this is like twenty dollars but I
got it because it's San Francisco and
everything
but it's a pretty normal black umbrella
there's really nothing special about it
but I like that I can just like keep it
in my backpack it's not too big and he
helps keep me dry so yeah okay so the
next one's really important this is my
water bottle it's one of the hydro flask
ones I really the color because it's
hard for me to forget it and it's really
bright but I I really need to stay
hydrated throughout the whole day or
else I get Hakes and I'm just cranky and
stuff so I bring this with me usually
empty because this thing is pretty heavy
and then I fill it up at work but I like
just having it on my desk so that I can
just like reach over and drink water and
this thing feels like it never runs out
so I bring this with me to everywhere I
go as well okay so the last couple of
things these are kind of like health
wellness related which again has to do
with my long commute so the first one of
these is eyedrops so I wear contact
lenses and so these are the renew
lubricating and rewetting drops if the
weather's really dry or I was on the
computer for a really long time that day
then my contacts dry out and it gets
really uncomfortable and so I bring
these along with me which really really
help I tend to get headache sometimes my
contacts are really really dry just
because my eyes are straining to keep
them like not painful and so having
these is a lifesaver I always keep them
with me okay next up this is really
Japanese but I have these like little
wet towels I actually got these when I
went to Japan this last time this one is
just one of the disposable ones that
they just like give you with your meal
and this one it was like like traffic
day or something to bring awareness to
like safe traffic safety things I keep
these with me because one of the easiest
ways to get sick is if you touch
something and then you touch your eye or
your face or something and when I'm
commuting there's a lot of germs
everywhere so if I'm like on the go and
eating or something then you know these
are really helpful actually along that
same vein I also have this with me this
is the dr. Bronner's lavender organic
hand
tiser which I picked up at the natural
food store in San Diego and I love this
I know they have like the gel hand
sanitizer stuff but I like this a lot
more it smells so good I feel like it's
like aromatherapy on-the-go and it does
a pretty good job of washing my hands so
yeah when I can't get to a bathroom or
something then these are really really
helpful and I honestly haven't gotten
sick this year so I think I have these
to think okay so those ones I wanted to
highlight specifically but I actually
have this kind of like first aid kit
type of thing that I made for myself
again long commutes are no fun and
meaning to wait an hour and discomfort
is no fun so I packed some of the things
that helped me feel better so that I can
just do things on the go now I will go
into everything in here but some of the
things that I have in here is lip balm
hand lotion band-aids warm packs pads I
think I have an extra pair of contact
lenses in here in case like one of them
rips as well as just like some ibuprofen
and vitamins and stuff I really like
this I actually like the fact that it's
orange because it helps me find it
easier in my backpack but yeah I bring
this with me everywhere I go as well
awesome so that is it for today thank
you all so much for watching hope you
liked today's video and if you did
please give it a thumbs up and leave a
comment down below about what tools that
you bring with you always on the go and
as always don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and click on the
notification belt to get notified for my
new videos again thank you so much to
Squarespace for sponsoring today's video
they have beautiful designer templates
that are ready to go for you to use so
you don't have to bother your one
designer friend it's also an all-in
platform so you never have to install
Pachter upgrade ever which means that
you don't have to fix any of the bugs
they have award-winning 24/7 customer
service and so whatever time of day that
you're working on it there are customer
service representatives that are able to
help you it's also really easy to set up
or transfer a domain on Squarespace and
so you can brand it with whatever you
would like and it's never been easier to
sell products services online and so you
can start that brand new merch line so
hi to Squarespace comm for your free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to Squarespace com /my you go for 10%
off your purchase of a website or domain
cool so that is it for today I hope you
all are doing
and I'll see you next time bye
[Music]